i i what i want to know is like how
cause if someone was like connor do you
want to do porn and i was like yeah sure
how do you adjust your mindset to being
like all right okay i gotta
do this like were you just like oh yeah
sure okay you just did it in the
beginning i was just curious
like my touristy was overflowing so i
yeah i'm so excited
but in the beginning i have to play a
role of like very
modest very shy like the innocent girl
yeah
like i only had sex with a guy a couple
times you know kind of thing
right right right that wasn't me
by the way so i couldn't say anything
like i could just say
just just be that kuderere
shouldn't say any virgo words oh okay
right
right like i don't know how to respond
like maybe can i just say it's good or i
could i just
i shouldn't want more just have to act
like the inexperienced
one right yeah like that's always a
thing like i've noticed that like if
there are
any new jov actresses that come onto the
scene yeah that's almost
always the first one that they do yeah
and i think you were saying as well like
the first couple of ones are like the
highest pain
right for some reason i don't know why
you think that the more you
do the more you get paid yeah yeah but
it's the opposite in the day of industry
yeah unless like you start doing
something more like you know
the back door or so every time you do
something new it's like it's like paid
more yeah oh okay
because like the first time i see that
first time is always the best time
for them and there's actually i have a
question you said you were in different
scenarios and acted different characters
do you have a script or do you have to
like ad-lib
everything because we have a script
rarely
outright it must be so annoying having a
script you're like i just want to do it
let me let me just say [ __ ] i know what
i'm doing and especially for sex scene
they
don't have escape at all in a script
is that a position and that's it right
right
hey ratio 69 just eat it
do not go longer than three minutes 30
on doggy over cancelling the shoe like
minutes in total
and do you have to remember that or does
like the other actor have to remember uh
in the beginning because like i was just
reciprocating
yeah i didn't have to do anything right
my director didn't want me to read the
script
because that could be too much acting
right i would have just loved if you
were just like in the position and they
just like busted out the scripture
all right what's what's my line again
chemo cheese